this lesson we're going to talk about
the very important concept of the
equation of a circle and how to complete
the square to find the equation of a
circle this is something they test you
on on the s80 it's definitely important
concept to grasp and understand the
first thing you want to know and
memorize is the equation of a circle so
this is the equation of a circle here X
minus H 2 quantity squared plus y minus
K the quantity squared equals the radius
squared so go ahead and memorize that
but you also want remember that H and K
those are the center of the circle the
center point of the circle and then are
here is the radius now notice this is
the radius squared you would have to
take the square root of this quantity to
find the actual radius so an example
would be say this is an equation here of
a circle in standard form you can see
that the center is actually going to be
at positive to negative 3 notice that
the signs are the opposite and then the
radius may be the square root of nine
which is three ok so that's just a basic
example this is already set up for us
the problems that are on the FCT are
slightly more challenging and that's
what we're going to get into right now
so see if you can pause the video do
these problems on your own will go
through them together and talk about how
to approach them but the first one it
says write the equation of a circle with
n points on the diameter of negative 2
comma 3 and 69 so go ahead and see if
you can solve that one will do it
together so here's the thing you might
want to draw just a quick sketch here
negative 2 3 is somewhere right here 69
is somewhere over here the circle is
going to look something like this we're
trying to find that center point and
we're also trying to find out what the
radius is right ok so the thing is to
find this center point is these are the
endpoints of the diameter right we're
going to have to use our midpoint
formula ok so the midpoint formula
another one is hopeful you might want to
memorize if you don't know this one
already it's the average of the exes and
it's the average of the wise so just
like you would think you're adding the
x-coordinates together and dividing by 2
adding the Y corners together dividing
by 2 so if we do that we get negative 2
plus 6 divided by 2 and 3 plus 9/2 which
we simplify that it's going to be 4 over
2 which is 2 12 or 2 inches
six so now we know that the center of
our circle is at two comma six right
right to up sticks so so far what we
have is X minus 2 squared plus y minus 6
squared right equals the radius squared
okay now to find the radius you can do a
couple different things okay one thing
you can do is you can say well I know
that my center here is at 26 I know that
a point over here on the circle of 69
you could use the distance formula to
find that radius put it in here and then
square it so just a quick reminder the
distance formula is the square root of
x2 minus x1 squared plus y q minus y1
squared you add those together you take
the square root that's all way to do it
another way to do it this way i like is
you just take one of the points let's
just say we take 69 we put six in for x
ok so that's 6 minus 2 squared we put
nine in for y so that's 9y minus 6
squared we can solve for r squared
that's going to be 4 squared which is 16
3 squared which is 9 so you can see that
r squared is actually going to be 25 so
if we put this all back together our
equation of our circle is x minus 2
squared plus y minus 6 squared equals
the radius squared which is 25 and you
got it okay example number to see if you
can do this one on your own the equation
of the circle is given by this equation
here what is the center of the circle so
they're just asking us for the center
but notice that this equation is not in
our standard form of a circle so we're
going to have to put in that standard
form so we can identify the coordinates
of the center so go ahead and pause the
video so you can do this on your own
we'll go ahead and go through it
together the first thing I would do is I
would group to access together so I'd
say x squared minus 6x and I group the
lies together so y squared plus 4y sand
just group your knees together equals 3
okay now what we're going to do is we're
going to complete the square so to
complete the square what we have here is
we have like a trinomial you trinomials
three terms like this right and what
you're going to want to do is you want
to take half of this middle coefficient
so half of negative 6 okay
/ you know half of it / 2 and square it
so negative 6 divided by 2 is negative 3
they get 3 squared is 9 so I'm going to
add 9 but if I add 9 to the left side of
the equation I have to add 9 to the
right because you're trying to keep it
balanced you don't to change the overall
equation same thing here going to take
half of 4 which is two and then square
it which is four so if we add four to
the left we want to add four to the
right so if we simplify here you can see
this is coming out to 16 now we're going
to do is we're going to factor these
trinomials now the way we set it up by
completing the square is that these are
perfect squares okay so this is going to
be X minus 3 squared + y plus 2 squared
now you can double check that by taking
X minus 3 times X minus 3 you see twice
oiling it you'll get back to Surrey
journal but a quick shortcut is if you
want to figure out how I got this you
can just take half of this middle
coefficient see your X minus 3 take half
of the scroll fish and half of positive
4 is positive 2 or plus 2 that's a quick
way that just go ahead and you know
write these perfect squares here okay so
there you go so that's the equation of
your circle right there the center is
going to be at positive 3 negative 2 now
some students make the mistake of saying
negative 3 positive 2 but it's actually
the opposite sign because you can see
it's X minus H Y minus K so you can see
X minus so it's actually positive 3 and
y plus 2 is actually like y minus a
negative 2 so it's actually negative 2
or you can just remember that there's an
opposite sign so this is your center
point here 3 negative 2 if you need to
go ahead and review this lesson again
this is definitely an important concept
to understand for the s80 and an easy
one to get right if you can understand
the basic equation of the circle and how
to complete the square I'll see you in
the next lesson